bienvenue françois bayrou jours merci
d'être avec nous sur ces news en direct
ce matin avec nous tous les partis tous
les grands partis sont aujourd'hui
groggy il cherche apparemment la parade
pour éviter une nouvelle hécatombe
est-ce que dimanche ils vont y échapper
donc je crois pas qu'ils échapperont
jugement des français
je pense que le dans le tréfonds des
citoyens du peuple des citoyens qui au
fond c'est forger une opinion au travers
de ces derniers mois il ya la volonté de
donner au président de la république les
moyens de son action
pourquoi d'abord parce qu'il y avait on
y reviendra peut-être une très grande
lassitude et un très grand rejet de
déformation principal qui ont fait la
politique depuis des années et
deuxièmement parce que ils ont vu depuis
quatre ou cinq semaines depuis la prise
de pouvoir
ils ont vu un président de la république
ils se sont reconnus dans la manière
dont emmanuel macron jeune président
incarnait la fonction c'est très
difficile incarnez une fonction incarner
que tout d'un coup on voit dans un homme
un président dans un héros dit séverin
sommes jeunes nous dit que c'est fait
est ce que tous les français ont vu à la
fois dans la vie politique
internationale dans la vie politique
nationale dans une certaine manière
d'être à la fois détendu et réserver
détendu et en même temps pas sous la
pression s'est alors vu un fraisier j
macron plus bas héros qui était être et
de droite et de gauche et du centre
en même temps ça donne des effets
essarts composent la vie politique le
paysage politique parce que ça va plus
vite que ce que vous aviez prévu tous
les deux ensemble au début
non ne nous nous étions optimistes vous
avez vécu avec nous toute cette période
chaque fois qu'on allait sur un plateau
de télévision chaque fois on nous disait
mais vous n'aurez pas de majorité
comment pourriez vous avoir une majorité
vous n'avez pas de sortant à la fois
pour le modem et pour en marche
réunis sous l'étiquette république en
marche vous n'avez pas de sortant ou si
peu mais alors qu'ils n'ont pas plu
majorié non moi j'ai toujours pensé que
les faits le la vague lancée par
l'élection présidentielle irait vite
irait loin
est ce que j'ai dit là mais est-ce que
j'aurais parié pour que ça aille tout à
fait aussi loin que ça peut-être pas
alors c'est que c'est que au fond d'eux
mêmes les citoyens les femmes et des
hommes ont décidé qu'il fallait aller au
bout de ce renouvellement
alors les enquêtes aujourd'hui annonce
une majorité absolue de chez absolue 450
455 est ce que vous y mettez le modem
oui bien sûr oui à l'intérieur du modem
bien sûr vous le modem sera un des deux
groupes de la majorité
et ceci est notre accord depuis la
première mais vous venez de loin
c'est en quelque sorte une je ne t'ai
pas une résurrection vous obtiendrait
autour de 50 députés pas plus au plus ne
soyons pas vrai a dit plus ne ya pas de
bois ici vous voilà dans che si vous
êtes sujet du bois non mais faut pas
avoir des ambitions limitées
c'est à dire vous pourriez dépasser les
50 je ne donne jamais de chiffres mais
je nous n'avons pas d'ambition limité
vous seriez déjà même à 50,60 peut-être
le double du parti socialiste pour usta
miracle samira qui vous permettait en
rejoignant à séparer tôt le candidat
une phrase une phrase c'est un miracle
c'est une stratégie s'est tue c'est une
vision qui tout d'un coup c'est réaliser
vision et une constrictor de ré que je
la porte depuis longtemps envers et
contre tout en vert et contre beaucoup
d'observateurs et sous les critiques les
huées et les sifflets et cetera
mais voilà la persévérance en rejoignant
très tôt emmanuel macron candidats vous
étiez indispensable dans cinq jours le
18 juin vous ne serez plus mais je ne
cherche pas être indispensable alors
j'ai lire le modem
et emmanuel macron à 400 députés vous 50
on peut même se passer du modem d'un
veut le mariage ne cherche pas à avoir
la clé de quoi que ce soit je lis des
papiers en dix ans mais en fait il
aurait voulu qu'ils en aient moins pour
pouvoir
jamais je n'ai voulu ni souhaitée ni
espérer une situation dans laquelle la
majorité serait insuffisante serait de
peu d'ampleur vous l'avez fait chanter
parce que vous pensiez qu'à un moment on
aurait besoin de vos mails à eau mais
qu'il majorité de 400 n'a pas besoin du
modem vous vous trouvez longtemps vous
vous trompez complètement je sais qu'il
ya des gens qui disent c'est
complètement faux ce que nous incarnons
à la différence du nouveau parti qui est
en marche
c'est un courant politique qui vient de
loin qui a son histoire qui est qui a
été un des piliers essentiels de la
résistance qui a fait l'union européenne
qui a une conception de la démocratie
exigeante et de la vie politique qui ne
ressemble à aucune autre dans leur parle
et on aura besoin de vos c'est ça que je
ne dis même pas on aura besoin parce
qu'il y aurait dans on aura besoin une
forme de menace je n'éprouve rien de
tout ça je me sens je vais vous dire
c'est bizarre parce que c'est
probablement la première fois de ma vie
je me sens en parfait accord avec le
président de la république avec le chef
républicain harmonie avec françois
bayrou qui est en harmonie avec emmanuel
macron présidence est exaltant je me
sens en confiance et beaucoup de
français comme moi si vous me disiez
mais quelles différences avez vous qu
elles n'eurent je n'en vois pas je je
vois ses intentions ses intentions sont
juste normal pour le pays honore pas et
c'est exactement ce qu'ils lisent comme
mon excellent confrère eric le boucher
dans l'opinion que le maquereau nice met
à renouvellement mais le renouvellement
d'une élite par une élite qui coupait
des classes populaires et bien je ne
crois rien de tout ça je pense que ce
qui s'est exprimé à l'élection
présidentielle au travers de cette
majorité de nous
c'est quelque chose que vous vous
souvenez j'avais devant vous défendu
quand est sorti mon dernier livre le
pays en avait marre du pessimisme les le
pays non le pays
le pays profond ceux qui ont des
difficultés dans le travail
ceux qui ne se sentent pas bien dans le
monde dans lequel tous en avaient marre
du pessimisme est ce que la majorité
nouvelle a apporté emmanuel macron à
porter à incarner
c'est au fond le choix de d'affronter
l'avenir sans en avoir peur et il n'est
pas vrai que les classes populaires soit
à l'écart de ce mouvement
le pain françois bayrou le party les
républicains est au bord de la scission
il ya beaucoup de députés d'élus qui
sont complètement paumé antilles sont
divisés entre ceux qui sont prêts à
voter la confiance si un vote de
confiance avec edouard philippe
la semaine prochaine ou à voter des
réformes et d'autres qui sont opposés
par principe
qu'est ce que vous dites ce matin aux
modérés tout à l'heure vous me disiez au
fond les deux grands partis ont perdu
sont écrasés moi je crois qu'il faut en
voir la raison il ya une première raison
qu'on a esquissé c'est l'usure le des
pratiques d des méthodes l'usure y
compris des d'effets les avant l'heure
dite mais là mais la deuxième la
deuxième raison c'est que les français
en ont assez de la guerre de tranchées
d'un camp contre l'autre
quelles que soient les idées de celui
qui parle
quoi qu'ils pensent au plus profond de
lui même
que fait-il il dit ceux qui sont mes
adversaires ont tort surtout hélas
voleurs dit ce matin j'ouvre amant tour
les bras qui viennent je ne caricature
pas mais je dis que ce que les français
attendaient et que pour ma part j'ai
plaidé
longtemps ce que les français
attendaient c'est que dans une situation
de crise aussi profonde
on s'y met tous donc avec nos différents
dix ans la place le compteur est passé à
des projets importants demain quand ses
demis vous présenter les trois projets
de lois de moralisation de la vie
publique qui s'appelle maintenant
redonner
confiance dans la vie démocratique les
trois sont prêts les trois sont très
bien sûr bon mais les trois sont prêts
mais je n'ai pas l'intention que ce soit
bouclé définitivement fini on va avoir
un débat parlementaire
on va avoir un débat civique il ya des
formations politiques en marche modem
les verts qui m'ont dit mais nous on
veut se saisir de ce de ce sujet et
réfléchir avec nos membres
je suis tout à fait prêt on s'entend
roger mékhé ouvert je suis prêt et à
l'assemblée à accepter des amendements
si ces amendements sont utiles au projet
il ya sûrement des chapitres à l'homme a
ouvert et prévoyez une réforme la
constitution pour supprimer la cour de
justice de la république ça change pas
seoul en mai peut-être faut expliquer ce
jambes et annuellement dans une demi
phrase la cour de justice de la
république c'était une justice
d'exception pour les ministres qui
n'étaient pas jugés par des magistrats
devaient juger par leurs pairs
parlementaire est-ce que ça va non ça va
pas et il faut en sortir et il faut
avoir une justice la même porte au slam
la même pour tous avec l'allergie plus
de trois mandats hydatique et successifs
de députés de sénateurs et où d'exécutif
local sauf pour important oui pour les
petites communes ça vous confirmez
l'autre projet doivent à interdire de
recruter des membres de sa famille pour
les ministres et parlementaires
les collaborateurs de cabinet des élus
locaux si c'est pas respectées il ya des
sanctions bien sûr c'est interdit par la
loi donc y aura des sanctions
les députés d'un marché moderne pour une
raison très précise c'est parce que tout
le monde a vu que le risque était un
risque d' améliorer ses fins de mois en
embauchant des membres de la famille ça
bien les députés modem est les députés
viennent souvent de la société civile
vous vous en flat et ils ont des métiers
les uns les autres
est ce que chacun ne devient pas lui
seul un lobby non je crois pas je ne
crois pas joyeux pour les gens de nature
je suis je suis sûr de toute façon il y
aura une interdiction pour que les
conflits d'intérêts ce que vous dénoncez
c'est à dire des élus qui se font le
porte-parole d'intérêts privés
dans la loi un texte qui rendra
impossible cette dérive en vous
supprimez la réserve de l'assemblée j'ai
calculé 90 millions d'euros
les réserves du sénat 56 millions
d'euros
mais vous allez créer un fonds d'actions
pour les territoires et les projets
d'intérêt général
oui quelle est la différence c'est à
dire que cette fois ci on verra pas
comment les comptes se feront qui sera
le maître décideurs les assembler les
assemblées de manière transparente avec
des critères et des contrôles de manière
que ce ne soit pas l'arbitraire et le
clientélisme qui préside à cela parce
que c'est vrai que souvent il s'agissait
de donner un coup de main à la
construction d'une salle commune dans un
village mais vous voyez bien que ce
n'est pas la même chose si c'est clair
et avec des critères et si tout le monde
sait à quoi ça sert à rien on retrouve à
monsieur le ministre de la justice
des innovations qui ressemblent à ce que
vous venez dire votre projet sur ce
thème enough
il va créer une banque publique de la
démocratie au passage une éditrice c'est
une et des dieux du ministre qui porte
la loi me moins deux mois cette banque
de démocratie pour accorder des prêts
aux candidats et aux partis politiques
au front national aussi bien sûr je suis
pas souvent du même avis que madame le
pen comme vous savez sur beaucoup de
sujets mais sur ce point
lorsqu'elle est pas seulement l demandé
à mélenchon demande est en marche
demandé nous dit mais c'est impossible
d'obtenir dans un certain nombre de
situations politiques même cantona les
garanties nécessaires
en fait c'est impossible de te d'obtenir
des prêts à dire qu'on l'avait privé je
l' ai vécu est ce que je ne suis pas le
seul à dire emmanuel macron au début
je pense qu'il a été dans le même cas
c'est à dire les grandes banques privées
ne soutiennent que les grands partis qui
ont pignon sur eux n'ont soutenu que
cela ou deux préférence cela n'est ce
pas
sans les moyens la démocratie n'existe
pas et même si vous avez les garanties
nécessaires garanties qu'on peut
améliorer poussé fait renaître pour que
la démocratie puisse s'exprimer
supprimer cette obligation d'aller faire
la queue dans les banques pour dire est
ce que par hasard nous les femmes nous
avons une république de la démocratie
cieux françois bayrou les parties seront
à la merci de cette banque publique pas
dû la démocratie parce qu'elle peut être
soumise elle aussi aux majorités qui
changent et bien sûr mon frère nous
allons prendre devient à la botte de ces
dans le débat nous allons prendre les
précautions nécessaires pour que tout le
monde soit assurée je prends un exemple
la caisse des dépôts et de consignation
qui comme vous le savez gère le
patrimoine des français c sa la pa le
patrimoine du pouvoir le patrimoine des
français
la banque la banque là la caisse des
dépôts et consignations elle est sous le
contrôle du pluralisme donc la banque
cela sera la même chose y aura tout
essayé garanties nécessaires pour que
personne ne puisse dévoyer la décision
de presse que cette demeurant si jamais
c'était le cas le la possibilité
d'emprunter auprès d'autres
établissements bancaires demeurera il y
aura une déclaration obligatoire et les
banques
cette banque de la démocratie est ce
qu'elle pourra prêter aux syndicats je
pense que c'est un sujet que nous devons
ouvrir parce que vous voyez bien qu'il
va y avoir de grands débats autour des
syndicats notamment autour de la
formation professionnelle et donc moi je
ne verrais que des avantages à ce qu'il
y ait en chantier dès qu'on a su qu'il y
ait un système pub et à condition qu'il
y ait des garanties parce que par ça
n'est pas fait pour gaspiller l'argent
des français en aucune manière ni
l'argent public
il y aura toutes les garanties
nécessaires sous forme de
[Musique]
caution ou sous forme d'assurance ou
sous forme de caution mutuelle pour on
avance avec le ministre de la justice la
loi antiterroriste pour la sortie de
l'état d'urgence elle devait être prête
le 21 juin elle sera prête à s qu'il
faut puisqu'il s'agit de protéger les
français qui sont menacés par des
terroristes qui se manifeste tout le
temps est ce qu'il faut accepter une
diminution contrôle et des libertés
l'objet de la loi est de protéger les
français et les libertés des français
alors je vais reprendre cette idée
état d'urgence qu'est ce que c'est c'est
une période d'exception dans laquelle un
certain nombre de libertés peuvent être
amoindrie ou suspendus liberté de
manifester liberté d'avoir son son
domicile personnel protégé et on peut
ainsi faire la liste
or cet état d'urgence en raison de
toutes les règles de droit et
constitutionnel il doit il ne peut être
que temporaire
c'est là c'est l'arrêt pour ça que vous
faites et dont fiat loi anti gay s'agit
il s'agit d'en préparer la sortie qui
est légal qui est obligatoire mais il ya
une chose que nous ne pouvons pas faire
c'est amoindrir la défense de la société
française contre les terroristes qui
nous menace comme une menace
toutes les sociétés calendes européennes
occident terroriste le calendrier est
bien la semaine prochaine le 21 nous
l'examen après ou qu'on s'implique
ministre
et après au 1er novembre en principe le
relais sera pris pour qu' un certain
nombre de dispositions qui ne
s'appliqueront qu'aux terrorisme avec
des éléments tout à fait des garanties
quant aux décisions des citoyens
constitutif pour qu'on ne puisse pas
l'étendre à d'autres mais le terrorisme
doit être surveillé combattu prévenu et
s'il le faut évidemment sur abba héros
et à ces deux textes dont on a parlé la
moralisation et en même temps la loi
mais c'est tout il n'y a pas de grands
chantiers ou une grande réforme de la
justice à bailleau moi il ya deux
à de grands chantiers ouverts et que je
veux ouvrir et porter le premier c'est
le statut du parquet l'indépendance des
procureurs qu'on puisse savoir qu'on
puisse aller au bout de cette idée que
les procureurs
ils portent des politiques pénales des
politiques de de prévention et des
politiques de de sanctions de tous le
garde des sceaux elle intervient plus
est ces politiques pénales sont portés
par des procureurs avec des instructions
générales des textes qui disent voilà ce
qu'ils eurent une forme capitale ils ont
été faits du 6 mai ses procureurs
doivent être indépendants garantie dans
leur indépendance
et c'est cette garantie d'indépendance
des parcs et des procureurs que très
vite nous allons ouvrir un chantage et
matin est la deuxième chose les prisons
la situation des prisons tous les
français savent à quel point elle est
insupportable
l'ignoble et je pense qu'il faut que
nous allions profondément dans cette
question pour que la france soit sûr que
son institution pénitentiaire et
responsable solide et qu' elle peut
remplir le rôle qui doit être le sien en
respectant ce qui doit être respectée ce
qu'ils doivent être respectés et en
étant en même temps une garantie pour la
société entière
je veux non seulement ouvrir ce chantier
mais connaît au bout de ce chantier et
il ya peut-être une dernière chose je
pense que le l'administration de la
justice le fait que ya tout le temps des
textes qui sortent et qui se multiplient
doit être soit récentes seront
interrogés c'est vrai quand je vois
qu'ils eurent vous êtes vous avez les
grands chantiers 50 nl soixantaine de
pages il en avait parlé ici même à
seignosse entre l'elysée le gouvernement
et des journalistes
beaucoup ressentent une sorte
d'agacement réciproque et de tensions
croissantes vous même et ce qu il est
vrai que vous avez appelé directement un
de mes confrères
quand je vous appelle directement vous
ne trouvez pas pour l'engueuler parce
que je peux très bon mais voilà là non
donc je je veux dire une seule chose je
suis un défenseur de la liberté de la
presse
je les ai été toute ma vie j'ai toute ma
vie participer au débat démocratique
au travers de là mais il ya aussi une
autre liberté que les citoyens
ressentent et dont il dans les citoyens
ressentent le besoin
il ya aussi une liberté de critique de
la presse quand on a le sentiment que un
certain nombre de pratiques ne sont pas
eu d'accord mais tant que garde des
sceaux où les milices de l'agency ce
téléphone c'est une pression quand vous
m'appelez vous appelez panne des sceaux
temps nous parlons sa nouvelle arrive de
parler vous appelez pas le garde des
sceaux
vous avez relève françois bayrou que
vous connaissez depuis quelque temps en
qui vous arriver un jour aller est
confiant quoi vous l'avais appelé mais
vous exposez journal il en mai celui qui
a été appelé est ce que c'est parce que
l'enquêté était embarrassante cas d'une
parce que vous ne voulez de la curiosité
a dû tout l après je aucune enquête
n'est embarrassante pour nous alors à ce
que nous avons toute notre vie politique
et dans tout notre mouvement choisi
d'être parfaitement alors justement mais
lorsqu'il ya des pratiques qui sortent
de ce que je considère être le respect
des individus un bain j'ai le droit de
le dire parce que ça n'est pas en deux
en devenant garde des sceaux je ne suis
pas devenu le muet du sérail france
jamais je n'ai jamais non plus alors je
lui ai demandé je n'ai pas perdu mes
émotions je n'ai pas perdu mes
enthousiasmes
je n'ai pas perdu mes indignations et
bien alors et je ne la leur au jarret
indignés ou en colère si je vous demande
où on l enquête lancée contre le modèle
est contre vous même aucune enquête
n'est lancée contre le modem et encore
moins contre moi il ya une enquête qui a
été ouverte par le procureur pour
vérifier si une dénonciation anonyme
dénonciation anonyme je veux rappeler sa
étaient fondées alors cette dénonciation
anonyme elle a une caractéristique
particulière c'est que tout le monde
sait tous les journalistes savent qui
est l'auteur de la dénoncer
l affaire remonte à 2010 2011 c'est une
dénonciation au coude et anonyme parce
que le journal du dimanche cite et
mathieu elle donné le prénom mais pas
lille est l'initiale du nom vous vous
savez qui c'est non seulement je sais
qui c'est mais vous le savez non mais
les gains de vos collaborateurs en place
ou le monde plus que c'est une chose
donner le nom il ya une chose
moi je ne je ne pratique pas la
dénonciation qui va le grill et je dis
une chose on va rester dans le
brouillard et nombre vous allez le donne
et si vous faites votre travail
ça n'est pas ça la question la question
ce n'est pas qui est le nom la question
c'est quelle est la fonction de celui
qui pratique la dénonciation à neuilly
l'aller et sépia les lettres et c'est
peut-être la raison pour laquelle on on
protège et ans est un onni pros tels les
journalistes qui savent très bien de
quoi il s'agit on protège cet anonymat
là parce que on s'apercevrait alors
quelle est la vraie n'est d'accord selon
l'accusation trois jours avant le
premier tour des élections législatives
donc c'est une opération politique
vous l'avez dit et il suffit de regarder
quel essai c'est une opération politique
ou un règlement politique à quelques
jours du vote
c'est exactement ce l'impression qui est
la mienne je n'ai pas le droit de
m'exprimer et ne m'exprimerai pas sur ça
mais on sait le prénom et le nom se voit
la personne à travailler avec vous et
est aujourd'hui vous dites cette
fonction de cette fonction où est il
voulait je dis oui oui il travaille à la
mairie de paris non travail avait il est
un des co la botte direct de la maire de
paris à ses parents plus est pas là
c'est pas à la mairie donc donc et donc
vous avez dit que c'est une opération
politique dont il y aurait derrière dont
annie d'un brin ce faire je pourrais ce
faire qu'il y ait un lien entre ceci et
cela remet quel intérêt youri tels des
élections législatives vous avez suivi
dimanche dernier les élections
législatives oui ça les regarde les gens
à regarder les gens achi se présentait
et ceux qui ont été éliminés vous aurez
peut-être des réponses aux questions
opération politique la mairie de paris
et peut-être mais le maire de paris mais
non non non non non non non
il y à une enquête
cette enquête est conduite par des
responsables des magistrats des enfants
c'est au parlement repères ville et des
policiers en qui j'ai toute confiance
oui et je sais que tous mes
collaborateurs au travers du temps sont
dans une situation parfaitement
transparente que tous les contrats de
travail que tous les bulletins de
salaire gelé offert dix fois sont à la
disposition de qui veut il n'y a rien de
plus un nouveau les rangs ce débat
public d'abord bravo mais au modem j'ai
dit ils sont chez nos avocats et c'est
très facile de les convaincre qu'ils
seront publiés si vous même vous êtes
interrogé est-ce que vous accepteriez
s'il fallait être auditionnée sans aucun
doute je demanderai au conseil des
ministres l'autorisation d'être entendu
parce que je considère qu'on doit
répondre aux questions que les
magistrats vous pose c'est avec le
risque est interrogé par par un des
magistrats qui dépendent
hiérarchiquement de vosnon il se trouve
que non
j'ai demandé par instruction écrite de
ne pas être tenu au courant de de
l'évolution de cette enquête
vous savez que la loi fait qu' un
certain nombre d'indications sur les
enquêtes remonte au garde des sceaux
j'ai demandé par instruction écrite
depuis déjà plusieurs jours que donc
s'agisse on vous attendait reîtres a
peut-être appelé mais est ce que ça veut
dire aussi que c'est la justice souhaite
entendre les députés modem qui sont
aujourd'hui deux ministres de la défense
de ligue ou là et marié lainesse de
l'europe
elles peuvent être également en tant que
nous nous avons toujours répondu à cela
vous estimez vous n'avez rien à vous
reprocher au modem c'est pas que
j'estime j'ai une certitude que les
magistrats établiront way et ce matin
vous dites qu'il n'y avait pas de la
part à l'époque de marielle sarnez et de
sylvie goulard deux ministres
aujourd'hui ou peut-être de vous même
l'utilisation d'emplois fictifs au
parlement de strasbourg la preuve au
très facile à établir
la preuve est très facile à établir et
je n'ai aucun doute qu'elle sera établi
quelle est la nature de vos relations
aujourd'hui avec emmanuel macron
candidat devenu président de la
république je vous ai dit rarement dans
ma vie j'ai été en confiance aussi
spontanée avec un président de l'areq
c'est l'idylle qua non je dis pas
l'idylle tous hâte c'est ce sont des
citoyens des hommes des femmes qui
partagent un idéal qui croient à la même
chose qu'ils ont entre les mains la
possibilité de le mettre en avant que ça
va au delà du pacte que vous avez
conclure et vue oui oui mais elle vraie
attention
or ça va elle nous savons que ça va être
difficile
et tous les français le savent tous ceux
qui nous regardent savent que ça va être
difficile
ils savent que la situation n'est pas
bonne et qu'on va vous dire et on
découvrira les 4 vous savez que vous
savez que la cour des comptes va rendre
un audit de la situation réelle du pays
on verra ce qu'il en est c'est difficile
c'est exigeant mais nous sommes
déterminés à aller jusqu'au bout du
renouvellement profond que la vie
politique est vide et la société
française attendent et faites attention
parce que tout nouveau tout beau il faut
que c'est un an
oui j'adore mairie on se reverra ray il
ya des moments ça a été le cas la
libération ça a été le cas en 58 ou le
pays a tellement besoin d'une
refondation 80 d'une refondation
cette refondation elle est là de nouveau
on va pouvoir avoir confiance en tout
cas se battre pour çà sent que les
intérêts partisans
l'emport général est revenue françois
bayrou à la prochaine et demain je
recevrai la nouvelle ministre du travail
madame muriel pénicaud
merci